seven-time Grammy Award winner that's
Gloria Estefan is using her music to
spread a urgent message about staying
home
[Music]
help
[Music]
very nice the singer/songwriter rewrote
the lyrics of her 1989 hit you know it
get on your feet now she's saying get on
your mask I like it Gloria Estefan's new
lyrics light up the Miami skyline every
night at 10 o'clock when the city's
curfew starts they're displayed on the
Paramount Miami world center and first
on CBS this morning Gloria Estefan joins
us from her lovely home in Miami Beach
there she is
hello lovely Gloria Estefan good to see
you
it's good to see you too in a way
Gail it really is a pleasure for me to
talk with you and thank you so much for
all that you guys are doing to keep us
all informed yeah we wouldn't want to be
any other place I I promise you that but
this is a thing normally we go to the
doctor's for help but this time a doctor
came to you for help what did he or she
say to you
it's dr. Eileen Marti who has been my
friend since were 14 we went to high
school together and she was very
frustrated that the message was not
getting out that we all anytime we're in
public or in a grocery store or any of
the places that are essential that are
the places were allowed to go then we
protect the world from us because since
we don't know who's spreading it even
asymptomatic people maybe that it would
just be far safer if we all wore a mess
she said Glo do it in your funny way
something that's gonna stay with people
because she knows I've done parodies of
my songs you know for forever and then
after that another friend sent me these
masks that she was making that that were
really you know fashionable and
beautiful and I go this is a universe
telling me I've got to step in and do
something so that day I wrote a parody
to get on your feet because I figured
when people hear this song they're still
gonna get the empowerment message that
was behind it and subconsciously they'll
get the positivity but at the same time
reminded me to put on a mask whenever
they're in public and not for nothing
Gloria it's catchy too but you've seen
the numbers you know that the
communities of color are being greatly
affected by this disease you know it's
been devastating to the black and
Hispanic community I would imagine
that's also another message you want to
hit to get people to pay attention
this is serious stuff it is very serious
and you know who's listening the best
our children you know my grandson was
right on it he understands and I've seen
him mature so much through this entire
process because they're facing something
that is unprecedented and scary if it's
scary for us imagine our own children so
I wanted to do something that was
kid-friendly that was gonna stick with
them and that's why since there were
different images on the mask I used
those to kind of bring different
characters to life and I don't know one
of my first songs was called dr. beat I
have the doctor code because I'm kind of
you know the family doctor everybody
calls me and humor you know has helped
me through the toughest times in my life
so I wanted to share some of that with
people through this song glory one of
your restaurants Gloria is delivering
free meals to healthcare workers down
there how did you make that happen and
what exactly are they doing well you
know we tried for a while to do the
takeout and we wanted to keep as many
employees as possible and as a matter of
fact our servers and bartenders we were
able there was a national chain of
pharmacies that had bought a Spanish a
pharmacy chain that we're looking for
employees and they knew that our people
had background checks and were already
vetted and they thought it was a great
changeover to bring them on but we
wanted to keep you know our chefs and
our people ready to jump in whenever
this crisis is over in the meantime we
thought what can we do to help those
first responders the people that are out
there really taking you know a chance
for all of us that are keeping life
going that are making life easier for
everybody at home and we thought you
know what better way than to donate good
meals for them to at least have a solid
meal from us daily we've been doing this
seven days a week we're gonna do it for
30 days and we'll continue it if we if
need be we had donations from our good
friends iris and Michael Smith Garry
Nader
art gallery and and the Milton family
and together with them and we donated
art places and services kitchen staff
and we're preparing preparing meals for
people that are on the front lines every
day
Gouri we're running out of time but I
wanted to know how you and Amelia are
doing I know you're hunkered down
together your husband of course and
what's giving you guys hope you know
what we're hunker down Amelia has to
hunker down Harriet is the studio which
we he goes to every day it's the same
core group everybody's healthy and
that's the only thing that matters
having like my kids or grandson for
close to two months now because we were
hunkered down in Miami Beach before
anybody else but we can't complain you
know where we're keeping positive
yesterday my son actually inspired me
with a conversation we were having to
write a song so I've written that I'm
gonna be reading from my Noel books and
putting stuff out for my fans on social
media try to stay connected yes and
everybody's getting more creative Gloria
Estefan is good to see you please stay
stay they say